what's up, Amy Civic Angel Look
what will happen to the idiot salla pie com from the
load, Hatip Aysal also slept in the
morning, remembering that the Qur'an was
as short as the effort finger at the end of
13.12 asks grandma
one-to-one check patients pasta com with
Subscribe to the villa, get neck, I gave up on you in the final, get it
now,
get love,
fear of this city, our longtime page,
God
God, how is the moment of my Lord
?
Where is that [Music] from Mahmut? Come, can you give me that salt
If
[Music]
It's great, these came.
I put you in a piece of salt, but
I didn't come after that. I don't understand.
Sometimes he doesn't perform the sunnah prayer.
You are breaking Yes he
Sunnah prayers are not different, not much
. When he calls him
, he can break the prayer because it comes on your right.
But when he called me the other two times, I
was praying the obligatory prayer.
prayer.